oui ils s'organisent à tous les étages
vous l'avez vu dans les catacombes petit
à petit une vie souterraine réellement
s'organise on voit des gens et bien
plastifiée des matelas pour bien pouvoir
tenir en cas d'invasion maritime russe
en cas de bombardement beaucoup plus
intensifs on l'a dit les premiers
bombardements sur odessa ont eu lieu
dimanche et puisqu'on peut voir aussi
dans la ville d'odessa c'est toujours
sur les plages ces hommes et ces femmes
qui remplissent les sacs de sable pour
barricader encore un peu plus la ville
il ya des barricades absolument partout
dans le centre ville derrière moi bien
c'est le fameux opéra dos des sacs qui
aujourd'hui n'est plus accessible on
voit également de nombreux volontaires
sains qui tente de récupérer un maximum
de vivre un maximum de médicaments de
produits de première nécessité pour
l'instant et bien continuer à porter sur
le front cela qui se bat notamment un
peu plus loin à micola yves par exemple
mais ils font aussi des stocks en cas de
combat plus intensif dans leur ville ce
que disent les autorités de la ville
c'est grâce aux fêtes et bien que les
combattons d'ukrainiens continue de
résister notamment à 1000 et nicolas
yves à 130 kilomètres d'ici une ville où
nous avons pu nous rendre et où les
bombardements sont très intensifs où les
soldats l'ukrainien réussissent à
repousser un peu le front de rue c'est
bien grâce à cela et bien les habitants
de ces ça continue à se préparer jour
après jour et pour être prêts en cas de
frappes de grande ampleur